كلنا ثقه ان الدول العربيه لن تستخدم
النفط كسلاح بهذه الطريقه خطبت الخارجيه
الامريكيه العالم حادث لغوصه نوويه
بريطانيه في اعماق المحيط وفد وزاري عربي
اسلامي في بكين قرار امريكي عاجل لمنع
انفجار كبير في الشرق الاوسط والوضع خطير
جدا الحكومه الاردنيه تدرس خيارات الرد
على تل ابيب والصين تسد فجوه الغواصات
امام الولايات المتحده لود استون في كيف
لابلاغها بقرار واشنطن العلاقات
البريطانيه الروسيه تمر بواحده من اعمق
الازمات في تاريخها وصيه لندن وواشنطن
لكيف بعين الاستخبارات الروسيه وطريقه
امريكيه لحل النزاع في
اوكرانيا واشنطن
والعرب ثقه امريكيه بالدول العربيه هل هي
ثقه بقوه الامريكان ام ان هناك اسبابا
اخرى هناك بمس شاريه الخارجيه الامريكيه
لامن الطاقه العالميه موس وكستين يقول في
مقابله مع صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز ان بلاده
واثقه من ان الدول العربيه لن تستخدم
النفط كسلاح مشيرا الى ان مستوى التعاون
بين الولايات المتحده ودول الخليج المنتجه
للنفط بما فيها السعوديه كان قويا للغايه
خلال العامين الماضيين خلال ذلك كان قد
وصل وفد وزاري عربي اسلامي الى بكين لبحث
التصعيد في القطاع ويضم الوفد الذي عقد
اجتماعات مع وزير الخارجيه الصيني وانجي
مسؤولين من السعوديه والاردن ومصر
واندونيسيا وفلسطين ومنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي واخرين فيما قال نائب رئيس
الوزراء الاردني توفيق كريشان ان الحكومه
تدرس الخيارات كافه واثارها على المصلحه
الوطنيه بالتنسيق مع مجلس النواب للرد على
تل ابيب وبعث الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيس رساله الى 50 دوله يطالب فيها بالضغط
على تل ابيب لوقف جرائمها في القطاع
لنواصل في المواقف الدوليه حيث نقلت صحيفه
ول ستريت جورنال عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن تكافح
لاقناع نتنياهو بمنع التصعيد وبحسب
الصحيفه الامريكيه فان مسؤولين في اداره
بايدن يشعرون بالقلق من التداعيات المحليه
المحتمله للدعم الكامل لتل ابيب من جانب
اخر اعلن نائب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جون فاينر انا واشنطن تجمع
معلومات حول الهجوم العبري على مدرسه
الفاخوره التي تديرها الامم المتحده في
القطاع في ال 18 من نوفمبر واضاف في
مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان انه اذا تاكدت
معلومات عن الحاق ضرر بمدنين يحتمون بارض
المدرسه فان ذلك سيصبح غير مقبول على
الاطلاق بالنسبه للولايات المتحده ليعرب
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه في وضع غير
قادر فيه على التنبؤ بموعد اخراج
المحتجزين العبريين لدى الفصائل منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الماض ضي فيما كشفت شبكه
سي ان ان نقلا عن مصادرها عن مسوده اتفاق
محتمل بين تلبيب والفصائل تتضمن وقفا
مؤقتا للقتال لاربعه الى خمسه ايام من اجل
افراج اولي عن 50 رهينا وربما فترات توقف
اخرى بعد ذلك ميدانيا شهد التلابيب
استهدافا صاروخيا من القطاع هو الاكبر منذ
اندلاع المواجهات بين الفصائل والجيش
العبري فيما دوت صفارات الانذار في عشرات
المدن والتجمعات السكانيه من اشدود جنوبا
وحتى مدن في شمالي تل ابيب ليصدر هنا قرار
امريكي عاجل لمنع انفجار كبير للوضع لكن
في الحدود اللبنانيه حيث افادت بوابه
اكسيوس نقلا عن مصادر بان كبير المستشارين
في البيت الابيض موساك ستين وصل الى
تلابيب للتفاوض مع السلطات العبريه لتلافي
الحرب مع لبنان في الدنمارك تجمع الاف
المتظاهرين في كوبنهاجن للمطالبه بوقف
اطلاق النار في القطاع في اليمن اكد
المتحدث باسم الحوثيين محمد عبد السلام ان
احتجاز السفينه العبريه خطوه عمليه تثبت
جديه القوات المسلحه في خوض معركه البحر
مهما بلغت كلفتها ضيفا ان بيانات التنديد
والاستنكار لا تجدي في عالم لا يفهم الا
لغه القوه لازلنا في الماء ولكن في اعماق
المحيطات حيث نقلت صحيفه ذا السن عن مصادر
مطلعه ان غواصه نوويه بريطانيه من طراز
فانغارد كدت تغرق عندما تعطل احد اجهزه
قياس العمق الخاص بها ووفقا لمعلومات
الصحيفه فان الغواصه التي كان على متنها
140 شخصا كانت تستعد للقيام بدوريه في
المحيط الاطلسي هذا وافادت وسائل اعلام
غربيه بان اسطول الغواصات الصيني يعمل
بسرعه على سد الفجوه التكنولوجيه مع
الغواصات الامريكيه في المعيار الرئيسي
المتمثل في
الهدوء اوكرانيا في مهب الريح اوكرانيا
والغرب شراكه شائكه تتلخص خص في المصالح
لكن ذلك ليس كل شيء هنا الكساندر كورنين
كو النائب الاول لرئيس البرلمان الاوكراني
يعترف بان البرلمان لا يمكنه التصويت على
قرارات لم يتفق عليها مع الشركاء الغربيين
الذين تعيش البلاد على حسابهم منذ عامين
ليصل وزير الدفاع الامريكي لودد اوستن الى
كيف لابلاغها بقرار واشنطن وقال اوستن انه
وصل الى كيف ويخطط للقاء القياده
الاوكرانيه واعلان دعم واشنطن لنظام كيف
الان وفي المستقبل فيما صرح امين مجلس
الامن القومي والدفاع الاوكراني اليكسي
دانيلوف ان كييف تشعر بالقلق من ان بعض
الدول الغربيه بدات مناقشه الحاجه الى
المفاوضات مع روسيا في سياق الصراع
الاوكراني الروسي مشيرا الى ان هذا
الاتجاه يرجع الى حقيقه ان بعض حلفاء كييف
يخافون من روسيا ليفيد السياسي الامريكي
والباحث في العلاقات الدوليه جون ميرشايمر
بالطريقه الامثل لانهاء الصراع بتاكي بان
انه لا ينبغي لامريكا ان تتدخل اذا جرت
مفاوضات بين الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي لحل
الصراع من جهته اعرب الرئيس البولندي
اندري دودا عن امله في ان تواصل الحكومه
البولنديه الجديده تقديم المساعده
العسكريه الى اوكرانيا وكانت روسيا قد
ارسلت في وقت سابق مذكره الى دول النيتو
ان اي شحنه تحتوي على اسلحه لاوكرانيا
ستصبح هدفا مشروعا لروسيا فيما افادت
الاستخبارات الارجيه الروسيه بان واشنطن
ولندن اوسط كييف بزياده سن التجنيد ليبدا
من سن الساعه ع حتى 70 عاما والقيام
بتعبئه اضافيه للنساء مع تكثيف اجراءه
التعبئه الى اقصى حد للتعويض عن الخسائر
الفادحه التي تكبدتها القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه خلال الهجوم المضاد الفاشل من
جانب اخر صرح مدير الاداره الاوروبيه
الثانيه في وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه سيريك
بليف ان لندن مصممه على على انهاء التعاون
التجاري والاقتصادي مع روسيا وانه لا توجد
طريقه لتطبيع العلاقات الروسيه البريطانيه
حيث انها تمر بواحده من اعمق الازمات في
تاريخها على الارض اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان القوات الروسيه دمرت تجمعات
سبعه الويه اوكرانيه وكبدتها خسائر جسيمه
في مناطق متفرقه ضمن نطاق العمليه الخاصه
فيما افاد الخبير العسكري دراجو بوسنيك
بان المزيد والمزيد من الاوكرانيين في
صفوف القوات المسلحه في البلاد بداوا
يعتبرون حكومه زيلينسكي عدوهم الحقيقي
هناك دع زيلينسكي وزاره الدفاع للتغيير في
استراتيجيه الجيش بشكل فوري لكسر الجمود
في محاور القتال للهجوم المضاد ياتي ذلك
متزامنا مع اقالات وتعيينات جديده شملت
كبار القاده في المؤسسه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الاوكرانيه
-